foreign
comes from Joseph in New Mexico Joseph
writes I'm 27 years old engaged to be
married and we have a young son I own an
I.T Consulting business that last year
made a 130 Grand in profit after paying
all expenses including my salary I'm
grateful for all the opportunities that
help my career in financial growth but I
feel stuck I've been putting more
thought into what I want to do with my
life and I realize I'm sacrificing a lot
of time with my family I want to slow
down regroup and regain focus on my life
but that feels impossible with all my
work responsibilities the other day I
saw how happy my son was when I was able
to clear my schedule and pick him up
from school it truly made me question a
lot of my past decisions I want to
change but I'm afraid that means I
wasted a lot of time growing something
just to shut it down is there such thing
as a work life balance
what do you think Dave
I don't think I'm qualified to answer
this well
[Laughter]
I'll go backwards no there's no such
thing as a work-life balance it's not
real it's a myth it doesn't exist there
are seasons right and there's seasons of
Madness and wildness right now we are on
the road I'm writing another book I am
all over the place and so back in
September or maybe it was August my wife
and I sat down and mapped out the next
four months and we knew it was going to
be bananas and we have built in touch
points all through that time because we
knew and when the kids asked for stuff
yeah it stinks and um it's also part of
it and because of this season it's going
to allow for a different season on the
other side of this thing so
um no it was not this thing as work-life
balance there's being honest about what
season we're in sometimes you wear a
coat because it's winter and other times
you're short because it's the summer
same thing when it comes to your life
um I can tell you right now Joseph your
kid was really happy to see you if you
picked them up every single day in about
a week and a half he'd be really tired
of seeing you that's just the way that
works man those moments are special or
great dog's happy to see every night
because I don't even know you've been
gone
um the um
yeah so I don't what we don't have in
this email or this um where Harvard came
in
um is what the number of hours you're
putting in and what your long-term goal
is and those kinds of things okay
in general
the idea that I don't want to work much
so I can play with my kid is not going
to work well with you long term
okay in general
no one in the equation is going to
respect or like you at the end of that
story
they're just not yep okay so uh in
general now I mean I'm talking like I
want to work 10 hours a week and I want
to uh you know be the uh
interfere with the teacher at the
elementary school because I'm there so
much you know that can I as you know
whatever uh so uh but what I think I'm
hearing is that you don't see any end of
this in sight
and I don't know how many hours you're
working if you're working 40 to 60 hours
and you're running a business and you're
paying yourself a salary plus 130 well
Welcome to the Real World right oh well
that's exactly right and the good news
is you're self-employed and if your kid
is doing a
uh Christmas play you can go you can
just decide I'm going to book around
that and you can go you can decide that
but uh do you pick them up every day
from school probably not oh well you're
running a business you work you're
earning my money for your family it's
not bad you're not a workaholic and you
don't have issues there's nothing like
like that going on
um and you're not burning out you're
doing fine you got a good career so the
only parallel I know is this when I was
30
two years old we started this show
I was working 16 hour days
ridiculous hours
during those times during that time for
about two years
my kids were little
my wife if you sat her down today would
still say something snarky about that
period of time about her being a single
mom
but during that time even though she's
snarky about it and harbors some
bitterness her life turned out okay I
can tell you that because we for a
period of time turned the heat up and
got the got the stove going
you know we got we got the thing cooking
and so then later on uh the next year if
there was a prom
uh we did not book live events around
the prom date if there was a uh I
coached my son's ice hockey
uh so that means on Saturdays and every
night whatever I was down there coaching
him when he's seven eight nine years old
that kind of stuff for years I coached
his ice hockey team and um
so we were there I mean we would go to
the lake and I taught them all to do
stuff behind the boat drug them around
on the tube throw them off and do mean
Dad stuff to them and all that stuff I
mean so we we have all of those memories
too but we also have a thing I did not
take 12 weeks off as the father
that was working when my children were
born
I took 12 hours off
and it never occurred to me had I taken
more than 12 hours off my wife who grew
up in the country where hard work is
taught uh would have said what the bleep
are you doing here get out you need to
get out of here you got to pay for this
kid you get your butt back to work so
what I hear in this is but but my point
is I've had balance come and go here or
there and then there's times it's winter
and you have to you have to turn the
heat up you got to go and right now you
know you got the thing running it sounds
like I don't know why you need to be
burning at 100 80 degrees it boil over
just turn the heat down a little bit and
work 40 60 hours 50 hours whatever and
then another week you know work 30. I
don't think this is about his kid I see
this over and over
um where somebody's 27 to 35 they've
gone all in on a particular career and
they found out they had to work they
don't like it or they have to work
really hard right or I thought this
would just be super fun all the time
whatever the thing is and then you start
looking around in your life for reasons
to do something different so what I
would tell you Joseph is if you want to
do something different own it and do
something different don't blame this on
your kid if you want to do something
different and
um you don't like doing it jobs but you
want to go be a police officer a
counselor go be a police officer
counselor you don't need to justify it
in a different way just just do it
um in a safe but here's the appropriate
way expect
if you're going to avoid mediocrity
in your life in any area of your life
you're going to work hard expect to pay
a price absolutely if you want to get
your body in shape to run a marathon
expect to pay a price if you want your
marriage to be good expect to
concentrate and be an unusually
intentional about that more so than your
idiot friends on Instagram that's right
you know expect to work hard at a career
over a long period of time before you
make any freaking big money that's right
and before you get to ah and this
Instagram world we live in where if you
just do this then you can have your
private jet next year it's just not real
man it's not real well and here you know
if you want to work four days a week
or you want to work from home which
means work part-time
and you want to do that expect the
different result
expected diminished return so because
here's the thing mediocre if that's your
target you're gonna hit it I had this um
Epiphany Dave I did something I
shouldn't have done way back in the day
and I got online and looked what this
the top salaries were at the University
I was working was and I found out my
boss made two or three times what I was
making and I was working 24 7 365 and
like a young idiot I got so indignant
and it wasn't two or three or four weeks
later my boss calls me and says hey
um I want you to start coming to these
meetings with me because I'm going to
teach you how CFO talks and how a
president talks and how board talks and
it was a gift and it was about two or
three weeks in and follow him around to
these meetings that I realized oh crap
he earns that money yeah he's like
smarter than me and stuff but he's
carrying the whole thing yeah on his
shoulder every decision that I make
reflects on him and he has to call make
the call on this and on this and I
realized oh there's no Free Ride man
yeah
those guys who put in the time and they
get this they make this money it comes
at a cost it's not the it's not the five
minute repair it's the 25 years to learn
how to do that repair five minutes
that's right repair that's the thing so
there's a price to be paid sir somewhere
in your life yep that'll give you your
work-life balance that'll get you there
that's what our gazelle intensity that
we teach us for a short period of time
you just go crazy and get out of debt so
that you can live without the stress of
death
price to be paid or you can be YOLO and
be paying payments the rest of your
dadgum stupid life